it was the greatest rivalry in racing
history and a battle that transcended
sports for DES vs. Ferrari and America
versus Europe an epic confrontation that
played out in the 1960s at the most
famous race in the world the 24 Hours of
limo
now thanks to a new movie the world is
about to get a new look at an event that
shaped a generation the driver is rushed
to their cars from the start of the pain
LeMans endurance crying it is the
ultimate test of both speed and
endurance the French call it the
infernal round 24 straight hours of
racing day and nights less than half the
cars that start at Lamont finish more
than 20 racers have died over the races
96 year history
in the 1960s the Ford gt40 equipped with
a massive new American engine took on
the most dominant team racing had ever
seen Italy's Ferrari the story on screen
features Matt Damon as the cars designer
Carroll Shelby cars Worcester and
Christian Bale his driver Ken miles the
stunts were coordinated by Hollywood's
top guy Robert Nagel tell me about this
this is a lot of fun yes it looks like a
lot of fun Willow Springs International
Raceway outside Los Angeles is one of
the places Shelby and miles used to test
the gt40 before it made racing history
ready yeah ready and it's where we
experienced its power for ourselves
career feel free to do it
[Music]
Neagle the former racecar driver has
worked on more than 80 films including
baby driver the Fast and Furious
franchise and black panther but he told
us this was different because of the
history of the race and the car what is
it like being in this vehicle it's a
little surreal I mean there's no power
steering there's no power brakes it's
all you
so it's a fast track this is a very fast
track
stuntman Derek Hill and Alex gurney are
both legacy drivers whose fathers one
atla mom Derek and Alex both did stunt
work for Ford versus Ferrari including
here at Willow Springs Derek what do you
want people to understand about what
what your father's did back then as they
watch this today these guys were in it
doing a life-or-death sport and they
knew that they risked their lives every
time they got behind the wheel you know
you were racing to win but you were also
trying to survive out there Alex gurney
even got to play his dad in the movie
the great Dan Gurney
passed away just last year what does it
mean to you to get to play your dad I
mean it's a strange feeling it's
probably the perfect role for me because
I've done no acting at all and don't
know what I'm doing so do you put
yourself in their headspace and think
about what they were seeing I tried to
definitely the depiction of the races
was as realistic as possible using very
little CGI Nagel helped design this
vehicle nicknamed the biskits that puts
the actors in a car on top of a flatbed
rig operated by a professional driver if
you didn't have this you wouldn't be
able to shoot movies this way no get
back to green screens and you can go
home fast this this is the slow on his
tops out at about a hundred miles an
hour and then the other biscuit goes 150
Nagle spent dozens of hours training
Christian Bale and he says was the most
dedicated student he's ever seen he
knows exactly what to do with the car to
make it look as if he's doing what he's
doing and completely sells it this car
changed racing oh yeah it's just a beast
and the speeds that it would attain had
never been seen before
this was in many ways the beginnings of
America taking on Europe in racing it
was about America taking on Europe and
racing in an American car before there
was a movie about all of this there was
a book ten years ago ajay beim released
go like hell it all started with a bad
business deal a Ford Motor Company tried
to buy Ferrari and the reason why is
very important because it's not just a
sports rivalry
it's an incredible business story Ford
Motor Company at the dawn of this new
globalism of the 1960s was going to try
to conquer Europe henry ford ii wanted
improved that his cars are the best that
people would go buy them Ford CEO Henry
for the second grandson of the legendary
Henry Ford failed in his bid to buy the
company from its founder Enzo Ferrari so
beating them at lamont became a grudge
match Ford poured nearly bottomless
resources into trying to win with the
gt40 transcends sport you couldn't make
it up because it was a rivalry that hit
to the most powerful men not just in the
automobile industry but two most
powerful men in the world that actually
pit two continents against each other at
the most famous race in the world during
the Golden Age of racing this were a
beauty pageant
we just lost looks aren't everything
the great race now all plays out on the
big screen a fitting tribute to the most
dramatic moments Motorsports has ever
seen the book go like hell is highly
recommended reading and the movies
fantastic to its past alone I'm the cast
and the car's a great story